hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Chinese film called igirl
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
a big tech company is introducing a
product called I girls 6s they are
robotic women mainly used for household
work but can be used in many other areas
of life the new version of robots have a
powerful and unique cultivation system
which allows them to develop feelings
for their Master unlike the cheap
robotic human-like toys in the market
igirl 6s are not just adult toys they
are the perfect girlfriends who one has
to develop a relationship with before
getting intimate for only ten thousand
dollars the protagonist is a young
Chinese man named Wang he is turning 25
tomorrow and has a well-paying job and a
beautiful girlfriend at the beginning of
the film we see him going on adventures
driving expensive cars and living his
best life however all of it is a lie
Wang's favorite hobby is lying about his
lifestyle on the internet he is as
single as one can be and has a lousy
office job but on social media he
impersonates a wealthy man who has every
everything he wants posing with fake
cars and mannequins one day Wang sees an
advertisement for igirl 6s fascinated by
the beauty and features of the robot he
doesn't wait a day before ordering an
eye girl of his own the delivery arrives
the same day much to his excitement
after getting her out of the box he
unwraps her face Wang can almost not
believe that the beautiful robot is now
his girlfriend he gets closer and smells
her before leaning in for a kiss but he
has to quickly rush to the bathroom to
clean himself before even touching her
on coming out Wang is surprised and
disappointed at the same time the robot
has woken up but she has dressed herself
in his shirt she explains that he has to
scratch her nose to officially be
registered as her master after doing
that she shows him the various modes she
offers like the sexy diva shy and sweet
smart teacher and a dominatrix Wang
quickly chooses the sexy diva unaware of
what her sub features are then he names
her Mina and introduces himself before
wasting more time he picks her up and
throws her in bed Mina repeatedly asks
him to get away and when he doesn't he
is electrocuted she reveals that the
latest version of igirl is not just an
adult toy she advanced in a way that a
man can get the true feeling of having a
girlfriend Wang will have to impress her
10 times and gain 10 Hearts to be able
to make love to her as he proceeds to
collect more Hearts he will gain more
privileges for example one heart is
holding hands two hearts allows him to
hug three hearts allows him to sub to
her twitch and simple day and so on
since Wang paid a large sum of money to
buy the robot he is unhappy about the
unnecessary rules but if he tries to
force Mina she will activate the
self-destruction mode that will cause an
explosion and kill both of them from the
next day he starts trying to collect the
hearts so they can move forward in their
relationship he takes Mina out to shop
and buys her the dress she likes the
most Mina is surprised because she never
told him which one she prefer bird
moreover the dress was way out of Wang's
budget because of the gesture he gains
three hearts at once and gets to hug her
but it makes Wang long for her even more
the next day he brings her to his work
where she meets his best friend chow
chow is confused about how the fake
mannequin girlfriend turned into a real
one it turns out that the man is a
pervert who upon finding out that Mina
is a robot wants to also spend a night
with her Wang refuses to allow him but
he doesn't stop pursuing Mina when he
gets a little too close she electrocutes
him teaching him a lesson at night Wang
can hardly fall asleep because of Mina's
presence in the same room he goes to the
washroom every time he wakes up to
relieve himself Mina registers the
problem he is facing and reminds him of
the consequences of getting handsy with
a robot he could get rovid
the following day Mina goes to Wang's
work to bring him food from home his
colleagues are aware of the lies he has
been telling the world about his
lifestyle hence upon seeing an actual
girl as his girlfriend they can't help
but spy on the couple when it gets dark
the two are walking back home suddenly a
pair of thugs stopped them and take Wang
hostage one of them approaches Mina
Smitten by her beauty but before he can
touch her she activates the red wolf
mode under the red wolf mode she gains
superhuman strength and fights the thugs
they are defeated in an instant after
that at home the couple watches Titanic
together seeing the actors fall in love
Mina feels a strange sensation Wang
explains to her that it is the feeling
of love and sympathy or maybe she's just
horny for Leo this heightens her
feelings and upgrades their relationship
level to five Hearts this means they can
kiss each other but Wang ruins the
moment by sneezing as they are about to
kiss they go on a walk after the movie
Mina gets an idea and runs to the other
side side of an over Bridge they yell
the names of famous lovers until they
meet in the middle and share a kiss
somewhere else Wang's perverted
colleague ciao also buys an eye girl of
his own the ten Hearts feature bothers
him so he creates a special hard drive
when it is inserted into a socket in the
robot's neck it will automatically
upgrade their relationship to level 10.
he tries the hard drive on the robot and
it works making her sexually attracted
to him who said nerds can't win in the
end the following day Wang is given the
drive he touches Mina with an excuse of
fixing her hair and uses the hard drive
on her she too starts making out with
him but Wang doesn't feel comfortable
with the way he persuaded her hence he
pulls the drive out and apologizes Mina
is happy that he understood his mistake
because Wang from a few days ago would
have taken advantage of her without a
second thought the following morning
Mina returns from the market with bumps
on her face and hands she is also very
weak and can hardly run on 12 hours of
battery it turns out it is because of
smog in beijing's atmosphere Mina's skin
was created in the west where the
scientists failed to realize the effect
polluted air might have on her to get
rid of the bumps she has to be cleansed
by soaking in water for two days
straight Wang helps her when she is weak
and takes great care of her because of
this their relationship upgrades to
level 10 and they finally make love a
few days go by in an instant then Wang
is kicked out of his job for failing to
impress a client Upon returning home
Mina greets him happily in which he
finds irritating she tries to cheer him
up but an arrogant Wang yells at her
pouring all of his frustration on the
poor robot in the following scene Wang
is with his friend Chao he has already
sold his robot to someone else in
exchange for another one he did so
because after spending a week with the
former robot he no longer felt attracted
to her Chao suggests Wang do the same
because a man can only be attracted to a
single woman for a short period of time
Wang takes his words into consideration
the next time he is alone with Mina he
forces her to make love to him Mina
tries to fight but eventually gives up
Wang stops Midway and apologizes but
Mina remains quiet still shocked by how
she was treated Wang cannot stop
thinking of her for the entire day he
feels terrible for what he did and
blames Chao for putting those thoughts
in his head a while later he returns
home with flowers for mina but finds her
missing she has left a letter saying
that she knows he doesn't feel attracted
to her anymore she doesn't want to be a
burden to him and is leaving to live her
life as a robot not ready to give up on
her yet when goes to the tech company's
headquarters the guards stop him from
going inside they reveal that all the
robots that are brought to the
headquarters are destroyed Wang is not
the only man who regrets treating his
robot like trash a crowd of men is
outside the building declaring their
love for their respective robots after
being kicked out of the place Wang goes
to chao's apartment to his surprise Mina
is on chao's bed betrayed by his best
friend and lover Wang cannot take it
anymore he throws a punch at ciao before
running away for the next few days he
does everything he can to forget Mina he
even goes to clubs to hook up with
random women in one of such clubs he
meets chao's ex-robot she reveals that
Mina always loved him the only reason
she left him was to protect him from the
CEO of the tech company it turns out
that he is collecting men's sperm using
the female robots for some strange
experiment Wang's life was at risk
because of mina so she sacrificed her
love and left him after finding out the
truth Wang cannot leave Mina to be
dismantled he goes to Chow to confirm
what the robot said was true upon being
threatened Chao affirms that Mina was in
his apartment only to put on a show for
Wang she knew Wang would pursue her if
she simply left and had to reluctantly
break his heart so he would let her be
in the following scene Wang breaks into
the headquarters of the tech company he
finds Mina about to be dismantled under
a plastic Dome the lab workers try to
stop him but he fight them and gets her
out of the Dome Mina repeatedly asks him
to go away because they're after him not
her right then the CEO of the company
arrives and asks Wang if he recognizes
him the man's face is familiar to Wang
but he doesn't remember who he is the
CEO senses his confusion and reveals
that he has been following him closely
throughout his life he stays in the
streets as a beggar comes to his house
as the delivery guy and Crosses his path
several times in day-to-day life all to
keep an eye on him and we thought Chow
was a creep he even sent Mina especially
to him to collect his sperm and use it
for experiments in the end he reveals
that Wang is actually the first Advanced
human robot Offspring the news comes as
a surprise to everyone many years ago a
scientist named Dr cha created a robot
with a nervous system that could think
breathe and procreate like humans the
robot had a half human child with a
woman who is none other than Wang
everything was going well until the Dr
cha found out that the CEO was planning
to misuse the robots for his own good to
stop him from doing so Wang's father was
killed while his mother escaped with him
they started a new life in Beijing but
the CEO soon found out about them
instead of bringing them back he let
Wang develop as any normal human to see
how he adapts then when he got old
enough the company decided to make more
hybrids using his sperm which is why
they sent Mina to his house the lab
workers are called to separate Wang and
Mina they plan to destroy Mina and keep
weighing Hostage to perform experiments
on him the two retaliate and devise a
quick plan since a forced sexual
encounter activates an explosive in
Mina's body Wang starts to tear her
clothes the level of their relationship
has decreased so the ACT is counted as
unwanted sexual attention the CEO is
busy enjoying the scene which makes him
forget about the explosive in the end
the entire building blows up killing
everyone inside including Wang Mina the
CEO
CEO subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
if you just said holy [__] out loud
thank you for watching